The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: We'll focus
on the third and fourth case
study.
These case studies which
were concluded on Thursday
with Chicago are
all examples of what
19th century urbanism or
more premodern urbanism
contended with.
They all contended more or less
with similar circumstances--
the rise of industrial
poverty, the weakening
of the aristocracy and the
royal presence, in some cases
the existence of walls
or fortification,
which is becoming redundant.
Chicago is very different.
Chicago has no royalty,
no autocracy, no walls.
So Thursday we will look
at Chicago comparatively.
Today, I want to look at two
case studies, one of Vienna,
which has a great
deal to do with walls.
And the second is
Barcelona, which
we're going to focus on the
most common emancipation
in the 19th century from
some of these problems.
That is to leave
the center of city
alone and build on
new land outside.
Cerda's plan for Barcelona is
the largest planned housing
project in the world.
Certainly the largest
housing project in Europe.
Let's start with Vienna.
Vienna was the major bastion.
Well, let me try to
explain what I gave you.
The first diagram is the
replacement of the walls
and the various sectors of
the continuous 2 and 1/2
mile road, which
became the urban symbol
of the post-feudal city.
The second is innovation
of Karl Marx-Hof, which
is this, an element in the
third stage of the city
from the feudal city,
to the liberal city,
to the socialist
city for a relatively
short time from 1919 onward.
The next page is the ensanche
of that part of Barcelona
which is based on the 1859
plan of Ildefons Cerda
is called the ensanche.
You can see the extended
pattern of the similar block.
The next page are the
two [? completely ?]
winning two finalists
in the competition.
Cerda's plan on the north.
The print is a little obscured,
and the alternative plan,
Antoni Rovira i Trias's plan.
We'll discuss this
in some detail.
The next page is an
element of Cerda's plan.
[? He erected ?] the same
square block, 113 meters by 113
meters, with options
for development
to create a flexible
environment in which
only a portion of
the block is built.
And lastly, the town in
Apulia in Southern Italy
showing the conventional plan,
which exists in smaller towns,
maintaining the central area,
developing a grid system
outside the central area
connected to the central area
by the gates of the walls.
OK.
Vienna.
Who threatened Vienna
from the 16th century
to the 17th century?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Islam focused its
threat on the West.
I'm forgetting about Islam
in North Africa and Spain,
but in Central Europe,
Islam made to major attacks
on Vienna.
1529.
They were repelled, causing
the building of walls,
enormous wall system, 20
years later in Vienna,
a wall system which had
11 bastions, a moat,
and an area called the
glacis, G-L-A-C-I-S.
It refers to the open space
around the walls to create
an arena for military
firepower, gun firepower.
You understand the concept.
So you have not only
the walls, but you
have a span of free
space like a green belt
around the walls, which
enables improved fortification.
These walls were subjected to
another major larger attack
by Islam in 1683, in
which case for two months
Vienna was on its last legs.
They managed to
subvert [? them ?]
by tunneling under the
walls, breaking through
from the south, and Vienna
was within a morning
of collapsing when
all of the forces
galvanized by the pope
in Rome to the extent
that he still had
support couldn't deflect
the energy of the Islam attack.
An extraordinary
event in history.
The Polish Catholic King
of Poland, John Sobieski,
had refused to take part
in the defense of Vienna
for reasons I don't know.
The last morning, Vienna had
already being penetrated.
The old city had been
virtually-- either
all the people had
been killed or left.
Sobieski decided to send
his cavalry south to Vienna.
They arrived, and Islam
had concentrated its attack
on the south of the city.
It didn't expect any
attack from the north,
so it was completely
vulnerable in the north.
Sobieski saved Vienna
in one morning.
There's a wonderful book on the
story of this whole episode.
If you're interested
in the book, tell me
and I'll give you the title.
It's an extraordinary idea of
the scale of an Islamic attack,
the organization in Istanbul
of the army, and all the food,
and all of the prostitutes
that accompanied
the army as they moved
through Hungary to Vienna.
That is one of the signal events
in the urban history of Europe.
Had Islam succeeded,
there might have been no--
I don't know.
Certainly probably no Freud.
Perhaps no Beethoven, Mozart,
and Haydn, et cetera, et
cetera.
I don't know how to claim
Islam's contribution
had it captured Vienna.
I don't know what
would have happened
to Europe, but Vienna was the
fourth largest city in Europe--
Vienna, London, Paris, Berlin--
and in many respects,
certainly in the last years
of the 19th century, one of
the major artistic centers
of European culture.
What year do you
think Brahms died?
Take a guess.
Brahms was born in about 1830.
He died in 1897,
as late as that.
He was the tutor of the
philosopher Wittgenstein's
sister.
Taught him the piano.
Gustav Mahler played music
in the Wittgensteins' houses.
The Wittgenstein family owned
12 houses in Vienna itself.
Wittgenstein-- do
you know anything
about the history of
modern philosophy?
Wittgenstein is one of the--
Bertrand Russell, the
British philosopher,
called him the greatest
philosophical genius
who ever lived.
He was interested in
architecture, and he had his--
oh, forget about that.
It's off on a tangent.
But Ludwig Wittgenstein
is an art product
of the culture of Vienna.
So we have a setting in which
Vienna survives in 1683.
Royal presence maintains
itself until about 1860,
in which the liberals
win in the government,
take over the government, and
start a process of modernizing
the city.
What I didn't mention in the
case of Haussmann in Paris
was the number of
things that Haussmann
did in the provision of parks,
open space, unifying the bus
system, improving
the infrastructure
of the city as a whole.
Other than the building
of these roads,
he's known only for the
avenues that he built,
the housing that he built on
either side of the avenues,
and for the major monuments.
But at the same time,
he built a repertoire
of infrastructure improvements.
The same year, the Danube
constantly flooded the city.
The city's always been on the
southern part of the Danube.
The walls were on the--
as you can see.
Today, the Danube fringes
the northern boundary
of the southern city by a canal.
The water flooding
problem was bypassed,
and in the same sense--
at the same time,
there was improvements
in the health system, the
first public hospital,
and a whole set of
improvements, but nothing
as major as the decision to
isolate the center of the city
and to build a new environment.
Instead of the new
environment being
similar to the plan of
Cerda for Barcelona,
he took the
extraordinary opportunity
for using the glacis and
the remnants of the walls
to build a single container
around the outskirts
of the old city.
This was a container
in which almost
all the sectors of a
new middle-class economy
could be satisfied.
Number one, from the diagram--
textile warehouses and
offices on the Danube canal.
Number two, financial center
on the Stock Exchange.
Number three, a university.
Number four, the
famous connection
of the parliament, the town
hall, the president's palace.
Number five, museums, number
six, music, number seven,
private apartments.
Nowhere in the connected
structure of urbanism
has there ever been
an attempt to build
one continuous movement
system accompanied
by surroundings as
diverse as making up
virtually the components
of a whole city.
It's a dramatic idea,
an incredible idea.
It had many of its
manifestations.
First of all, the
buildings are not
oriented to each other but
oriented to the street.
The street is everything
that animates the performance
of the buildings on its sides.
Secondly, instead
of as in England,
every effort was made to connect
the space beyond the old city
with its center city.
In this case, the old city
was where workers lived
and-- sorry, not the old city.
This is the old city,
where people were poor,
where there were factories,
where hygiene was
unclean and untaken care of.
[INAUDIBLE] from here to
here is equivalent in size
to the whole city.
To the old city.
Sorry.
I'm talking badly this morning.
To the old city.
So you've constructed a
new city along one line
2 and 1/2 miles long.
It should come therefore
as no surprise that in 1919
when socialists
took over the city
that they would concentrate
their efforts in the area
beyond the Ringstrasse.
Karl Marx-Hof-- we took a
look at in a little detail--
exists outside of the ring.
The ring didn't contain the
elements of the feudal city.
Since Stephen's Church was
not replaced in the ring,
the vote of church in the
ring is simply a thanksgiving
for Vienna's victories.
The royal palace
ensemble, which is
a large part of the
old city, attempted
to penetrate onto the ring.
Gottfried Semper did a
plan for the extension
of the royal palace site to the
ring, which has sort of softly
connected but not.
The presence on the
ring is everything
to do with a
middle-class economy.
It's the classic example
of a road space dominating
everything that surrounds it.
In a few minutes time when--
towards the end of
our story, then I
will concentrate on the
difference between proponents
of archaism like Camillo
Sitte and Otto Wagner,
the great modernist.
It's interesting, though, Wagner
the modernist was fascinated
by the possibility
that one could move
along a street and the street
could be there primarily
because it supports the
significant phenomenon
of movement.
The buildings on the
side of the street
had no unifying architecture.
In the complex--
I'll quote you from somebody
who liked the complex, which
is the city hall, the theater,
the university, and parliament.
I quote-- I ran from one
object of interest to another.
For hours, I would
gaze at the parliament.
The whole ring
boulevard seemed to me
like an enchantment
from the 1,001 nights.
Who was this?
He became a significant
figure in history.
Even you might know who he is.
Adolf Hitler.
He wanted to study
architecture in Vienna,
and they wouldn't let him.
Pity.
[LAUGHTER]
There was something
about this complex which
exemplifies the interest in--
not the interest
in, but the fact
that there was no consuming
architectural style
which could unify a street.
For instance, in this complex,
expression then was used.
The town hall is compared
to a free medieval commune
and is built in Gothic style.
The theater exemplifies
the aesthetic enthusiasm
and is therefore given
the Baroque style.
The university is the symbol
of enlightened culture.
It's given the
Renaissance style.
Parliament is democracy.
It's given the Greek style.
We did some work in
Bratislava in Slovakia.
Bratislava and Vienna are
the two closest capitals
in the world of
neighboring countries.
We had meetings with the
deputy mayor of Vienna, who is
the chief of Vienna's planning.
To find his office in
this Gothic construction,
this large Gothic construction,
takes almost a supporting dog.
[LAUGHTER]
It is still an
amazing construction.
Camillo Sitte archaism
was to counter
the flow of continuous
movement in cities.
For him, he would break up the
continuity by creating plazas,
had significant intervals
along the street.
I'll show you a slide for his
proposal for one of the plazas.
There was no such
enthusiasm for curtailing
the emphasis of this
middle-class continuity.
I'll just-- imagine
choosing to build buildings
according to an image of
the essential performance
and therefore to choose
the historical style which
supports that.
I can't think of it
being done anywhere else.
By concentrating on
the power of a street,
perhaps it frees you from any--
it allows you to
accept any device
to create the
architecture along it.
There's something about
a system of streets,
a simple system of
public ways which
may enable the
environment or which
supports it to be free of having
to perform those functions,
a continuous facade functions.
It's a thought which
strikes me from Vienna.
If you allowed Zaha
Hadid to build in Vienna
in the old city of
Vienna, at least
you'd have the
Ringstrasse to hold you
into some public format.
The trouble with the new Vienna
on the north side of the river
is that it has no armature
either of the old city
or of the ring structure
to hold it together.
You have buildings which the
entrances to the buildings
are unidentifiable.
It is the biggest load of
garbage I've ever seen,
done by some of Europe's
great architects.
This organization in
the ring structure
of buildings knowing and
showing where you enter them--
this is true of all of the
buildings of the old city.
There's a logic to
where a street is--
that the street is public,
that once you leave the street
you are directed by a building
[INAUDIBLE] performance.
It's a powerful conjunction.
The Ringstrasse is
about 200 feet wide,
which is about the width
of Commonwealth Avenue,
if I remember.
The housing on both
on the Ringstrasse
was private housing.
Again, the tradition of the
middle class emulating formally
the facade idea of
the royalty occurs.
I will show you slides of
the facades of something
called a [INAUDIBLE] house.
This is a condominium building.
The lots were large, and
the accumulated building
of a kind which we
now to accept is
common was accepted as the mode.
The financing of the
Ringstrasse was largely state,
but also the land was free.
So when it-- because of
the glacis and the walls
belonged to nobody
but the state.
So the money made in privatizing
the parts of the Ringstrasse
for housing or offices
meant a return of income
to the city, which they
could use for parks
and other public facilities.
It's interesting that throughout
the formal agenda of buildings
in the various cities,
from the feudal city
to the Ringstrasse of the
city to the socialist city,
certain archetypal ideas--
for instance Karl Marx-Hof
has sculpture on the facade.
There's flags on the facade.
This is a Marxist
socialist environment,
which still pays tribute
to the Royal appurtenances.
There's a strong sense of the
need to maintain continuity
throughout the history
of this modern city,
or certainly from 1860 onward.
A few words about
archaism versus modernism.
Camillo Sitte was an
architect and critic
who wrote a book which
had a lot of influence.
He was against the evident
preoccupation of modernism
with economic progress,
with speed, with fluidity,
with movement against
the rationalization
of traffic, and hygiene,
and the technology
which is appropriate for
that kind of performance.
He was much more
interested in the world
of the artisan, the
world of the guilds,
much like [? Raskin ?]
perhaps in London.
He was attracted by
the labor quality
of the guild, the disappearance
of the guild and the artisan.
He was a great admirer
of Richard Wagner.
He was fascinated by
[INAUDIBLE] [? work, ?]
the idea of bringing a genuine
folk art to bear on the city.
For him, the Ringstrasse, which
was a continuous open space,
was a form of
enclosure which was
antithetical to his view
of what a city needed.
A city needed places, public
enclosure, continuity,
understanding, a kind of
psychometric condition
in which everything
which was close to you
would fit to your emotional.
So if you saw a
big building, you
would appreciate its bigness
because it had a purpose,
and you had a continuous space,
a public space from which you
could appreciate its
emotional circumstance
rather than being disrupted
by the continuous flow
of an open-ended system.
Richard Otto Wagner,
on the other hand--
I might point out that Camillo
Sitte was not the only person.
He was an advocate
of the picturesque,
of the effect of the
emotional, but he
was one of the people who
started worrying about the fact
that city planning in Europe was
[? wissenschaft, ?] was moving
in its representation only of
the two-dimensional surface
of the city.
For Sitte, the third
dimension was being excluded.
Referring to Baumeister's,
the German books
on traffic engineering.
Baumeister's book of 1876
and Heinrich Steuben's book
of 1907.
Quote, the traffic systems
and direction of their flow
form the basis of the plan
of construction of cities.
So city growth, city
enlargement, city planning
was seen as a two-dimensional
exercise of the organization
of movement.
Wagner was too
sensitive an architect.
In fact, he was a kind
of hybrid personality.
The demands of efficiency,
economy, and physics
were attractive to him.
He was a modern man.
He believed the
city could expand,
and his project for
the expansion of Vienna
are reproductions of
the old city of Vienna,
about 100,000 to 150,000 units
all linked by movement systems.
He spent his time
building buildings
for the new Danube
canal sluice gates.
He did the wonderful
subway stop,
the [? car ?] [? plots ?] and
a number of the subway stops
in the new Vienna subway system.
At the same time, he designed
neoclassical monuments.
His great [INAUDIBLE]
Vienna should
go to see his small church in
the medical facility, housing
facility in the city.
It's been restored
with a golden dome
and doesn't look like anything
that a modernist would
have anything to do with.
Perhaps his most
significant building
is the Postal Savings
Bank on the Ringstrasse,
the only building that he built
on the ring dresser, which
has a rectangular
grid set of windows.
But between the grid
of windows, there
are [? French ?] tiles decorated
with floral decorations,
sinews, floral decorations.
You know, I've said most of
the things that I want to say.
Amongst Otto
Wagner's fascination
was what he called the painless
uncertainty of modernism,
which is an extraordinary kind
of comment that if you pay--
Wagner in my mind was a
brilliantly confused man
at the time of the
intersection of traditionalism
with modernism.
For those of you who want
to study his architecture,
look at the work of
a great architect.
He had an enormous influence
for a number of his students
were involved in the building
of the hofs after 1919.
But the idea of
painless uncertainty,
that one is not going
to be sure about what
is going to happen over time.
In fact, it is
impossible to know what's
going to happen over
time, and therefore you
have to try to understand
how to deal with uncertainty.
This is the first time that I
think a 19th century architect
or city person makes an
important statement about what
preoccupies a lot of the
thinking in the 20th century
and still does today--
that is open-mindedness,
diversity, change, and a number
of the associated phenomena.
We'll see in Cerda's
plan for Barcelona
an attempt to allow
for that to take place.
But just two other stories.
The post-1919 story.
The real estate speculation
after the rebuilding
of the Ringstrasse had resulted
in enormous increases in rent
for porting housing
conditions for working class.
And the 1917 census showed
that 73% of Vienna housing
was quote, in unspeakable
conditions of overcrowding
and hygiene.
Workers were paying 25% of
their income to housing.
In 1919, Vienna
became Red Vienna
with the socialist majority,
and Red Vienna has remained.
There's a book by
Eve Blau at Harvard
on Red Vienna which
is worth looking at,
but this was a time when the
London County Council in London
was established a similar
planning operation in Berlin.
From 1919 to 1925, they
invested in a radical policy
of land acquisition,
law controlling rent,
and the building
of new apartments.
By 1934, they had
built 63,700 dwellings,
equivalent to 70% of the entire
production between the wars.
Housing was something like a
tenth of the city's population.
There was a
controversy about what
form these new socialist
housing should take place.
Adolf Loos and a number
of other architects
proposed following
the German example
of the [? siedlungen. ?]
The siedlungen,
but the famous
siedlungen in Stuttgart
and so on were
examples of housing
the poor in green
circumstances with houses
which were single family with
gardens and self-sufficiency
that deprived from the
center of the city.
Another group of people
felt that it was about time
that the workers made
their presence felt,
and the way they could
make their presence
felt was to develop a pugnacious
housing response to the market
housing.
This took the form of
the hof, H-O-F. "Hof"
is the same word in
German as "court".
So by calling their
housing a court,
they have another reflection
back to the feudal city.
It seems to me that
revolutionists never
abandon everything.
They abandoned the
key variable, or they
destroy the key
variable, the market,
and maintain everything
else of a secondary order.
We look at this when we discuss
the post-revolutionary work
in Russia from 1917,
particularly to 1932,
in the work of the disurbanists,
and urbanists, and others.
Karl Marx-Hof of is the
largest of the enterprises.
There were a number of them--
[INAUDIBLE],, [? Viessmann ?]
Hof, [INAUDIBLE] Hof,
[INAUDIBLE] Hof,
[INAUDIBLE] Hof--
built between 1924 and 1927.
Karl Ehn, the architect
for Karl Marx-Hof,
is a rather
undistinguished figure.
He worked in the
city government.
He had done some housing.
Unfortunately, stayed on and
worked for the Nazis as well,
so maybe his vocabulary
was very widespread.
Karl Marx-Hof was
a pugnacious island
which built apartments,
1,380 apartments,
plus a large interior
space containing nurseries,
collective laundries, library,
offices shops, clinic,
and so on.
This period didn't
last very long,
and Karl Marx-Hof and
Red Vienna remained
as a kind of intellectual
fascination for our urbanists
afterwards.
Karl Marx-Hof is still
worth visiting today.
It's located connected
to the center
of the city by light rail,
by heavy rail, by bus.
It's easy to get to.
It's extraordinarily large.
Has anybody been to Vienna?
What did you see in Vienna?
AUDIENCE: Museum [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
JULIAN BEINART: I
don't blame you.
Wonderful museum.
You couldn't go to a
concert, I suppose.
AUDIENCE: No, I just--
JULIAN BEINART: There's no
democracy of tickets in Vienna.
I had to listen to the Vienna
Philharmonic play in Cleveland
because I've always wanted to
hear the Vienna Philharmonic
play.
Vienna Philharmonic
didn't include
women in the [INAUDIBLE]
until relatively recently,
so there are a
lot of throwbacks.
Their attitude towards Jews
is signally despicable.
Gustav Mahler who was
born a Jew and a bohemian.
In order to become the
conductor of the Vienna
[? Philharmonic, ?] he had
become Catholic temporarily so
that he could play music.
Extraordinary stories.
You should go to the
Judenplatz in the old city,
where the Jews were massacred.
There's a wonderful sculpture
by the British sculptor.
A woman-- I forget her name--
built a concrete sculpture
made of books as a remnant.
There's one last
thing about Vienna.
The last 10, 20 years of the
end of that century, Vienna
underwent one of the
great cultural performance
spans which we associate
with great cities.
We associate it with
15th century Florence,
the great painters, the great
sculptors, the Medici family.
This is a similar
period in the West.
We have the transference
from 19th century
romantic music to modern music.
Brahms died in 1897.
Schoenberg lived from 1874
to 1951, Alban Berg from 1885
to 1935, Anton Webern 1852
to 1945, Gustav Mahler
from 1860 to 1911.
These were the
people who invented
the post-romantic music for us.
You may not like the music.
Amongst them, only Mahlers
are now conventionally played
by the Boston [INAUDIBLE].
Very few people play Schoenberg
except in their living rooms.
[INAUDIBLE] opera is
performed now and then,
Alban Berg's music.
But this the significance
of a city, that it
can transform culture
in significant ways.
Why it happens in cities--
Austria.
Vienna was not it economic
after the separation of the--
no, that took
place-- it was later.
There are a number of theories
as to why this happened.
Peter Hall, the
British urbanist,
has written about this
in one of his books.
There's a sort of culmination
of the coming together
of all of the elements of
good culture in a place.
This despite anti-Semitism,
violent anti-Semitism
which was taken
over by the Nazis
when they took over Austria.
It happened in New
York from 1945 to 1970
with the invention of a number
of new forms of modern art.
The great painters,
Jackson Pollock and others.
I just mentioned it
because it's something
that is not indulged in.
Not many cities in the world
grabbed the world by its--
and it's very
difficult to explain
what in the history of
Vienna predicted this.
It's certainly true that the
great romantic composers--
Mozart, Haydn, and Beethoven--
spent time in Vienna.
Their music was
constantly performed.
People learned to
play the music.
Wittgenstein's
sister, as an example.
There were small
groups of philosophy.
The Vienna Circle, the
philosophers in the 1920s,
was significant.
There was music
played in houses.
People were familiar.
Wittgenstein's father had
a large set of children.
Three of them committed suicide.
They were all musically attuned.
One of them as a child could,
according to a biography,
distinguish between--
when a band played
outside their house,
he could tell what was wrong
with the band's playing.
He could tell which instruments
were playing the wrong music.
So there was a culture of
music built into the society.
I don't know if Freud had
anything to do with music.
He probably was too
busy with his trying
to understand the psychic mind.
So the Vienna story is an art
story of a number of things--
the move from a feudal to a
liberal to a socialist city
and then back to a modern city.
A number of things
that I've touched on.
It's one of the great
cities in history.
It's the only city which built
a single road to dedicate itself
to a new environment,
economically and socially.
And what else can
one say about Vienna?
It's still a city which
is remarkably well
cared for planning-wise.
The deputy mayor had
a staff of something
like 1,500 people in his
planning transportation
section.
It has a journey to work,
which is 60%, I think,
in public transportation, 40%
in private transportation.
It's done very well.
Barcelona is a smaller
city out on the fringes.
All of these cities of
course were Roman cities--
London, Paris,
Vienna, and Barcelona.
The story of Barcelona,
Cerda, and the ensanche
is a complicated story and
requires a lot of time,
so I'll jump very quickly.
The old city of Barcelona
with its Roman walls
and then its enlarged walls was
the densest in Europe in 1830.
It had 300 inhabitants
per hectare.
It was twice the density
of the very dense Paris.
It suffered from epidemics in
1834, 1854, 1864, and 1870.
Between 1837 and 1847, average
life expectancy amongst men
was 38.9 for the rich
and 19.7 for the poor.
It's difficult to believe
that the average life
expectancy could be
under 20 years of age,
but if you include the
infant mortality in that,
infant mortality takes a
large number of deaths.
So we have the condition
of an old city.
No apparent market for the
wealthy occupying the old city.
No program is in Paris or
London for the transformation
of the old city.
There was no royalty
in Barcelona.
Royalty was in Madrid.
There was a constant tension
between Barcelona and Madrid.
In fact, Barcelona claimed
a certain independence
for Catalonia, and
Catalonia has always
been stuck between
Spain and France.
Perhaps that's why Picasso
comes from Catalonia.
I want to jump into the
story of the extension.
The extension is the mark
of one man's thinking.
It was [INAUDIBLE] Ildefons
Cerda born in 1845--
sorry.
1815.
Decided to study engineering,
and at the age of 19
went to Madrid--
he comes from Barcelona,
went to Madrid to study.
Graduated in 1847.
Enlisted in the national
militia from 1841 to 1848.
He did projects in cities in
Spain, highways infrastructure
for the ministry of engineering.
He developed a powerful
political base in Madrid.
He returned to
Barcelona in 1849.
In 1854, the walls
began to be taken down.
Cerda did something
extraordinary.
He first of all decided to
do research in the old city.
In volume three of his book
General Themes of Urbanization,
written in 1858, he details
patterns of food consumption,
compares the old city
with other cities,
detailed maps, mortality rates.
He found that the
bourgeois had an average
of 3.6 cubic meters of space,
where the working class only
had 0.9.
That's four times less.
Imagine this man going
into the old city
and doing all of this work.
I don't know what
his ambitions were,
but this example of
research before plan
stands as the first
time somebody has
taken the obligation to
study existing facts,
especially above poverty.
Remember that Booth's
map in London was 1789.
No.
1879.
This was before
Booth's map of London.
This is not Engels
studying Manchester.
[INAUDIBLE] studied
Manchester partly
to gather the facts on which to
base a large universal theory
of society.
It's unclear what
Cerda was doing.
He just wanted to know facts.
He wanted to know reality.
He had no large theory.
Apparently he didn't have.
In 1859, there was a
competition for designing
a plan outside the old city.
Cerda and a man
called Rovira i Trias
competed for the final
of architects in general.
And most of the
people of Barcelona
preferred Rovira i Trias's plan.
Rovira i Trias took the old
city as the center, created
the [INAUDIBLE]
[? republica ?] north of it,
and from that point radiated
out five avenues out
to the perimeter.
This is a neoclassical plan
which was relatively common
in city expansion.
Cerda's plan was a series of
113 meters by 113 meters blocks,
all identical except for the
disposition of the buildings
on them.
So there was a grid system laid
out over an extensive area.
It could continue
without disruption.
Roads were 20 meters, 35
meters, or 50 meters wide.
There was six cubic meters
of space per person.
It was double the middle
income level at the time.
It was part of Cerda that
was extremely rational.
That formula that is on
the left is his formula
for the width of the road, x
being the side of the block,
2b being the width
of the street,
f being the depth of
the building site,
v being the number of
inhabitants per house,
p equals the squared
meters size per person,
d equals the height
of the facade,
all rationally
calculated to produce it.
The detail of the
formula is not important.
It's nonsense, but
it shows something
about the mind of a person who--
what's going on in his mind?
He's trained as an engineer.
He's worked in cities
all over Spain.
He returns to Barcelona,
spends his efforts
documenting poverty,
then emerges with a plan.
There's an interesting
side story to this.
The critics and writers about
the ensanche in Barcelona
were extraordinarily
loyal to the Barcelona
and to Ildefons Cerda, who is
considered a national hero.
By the way, the reason the
city chose Cerda's plan
over Trias's plan was because
of pressure from Madrid.
Cerda in his years
in Madrid working
for the national militia
had made friends,
and his radical plan
was forced on Barcelona.
Now Barcelona cannot be
happier about the plan.
Cerda is a great hero.
There's an aspect of
Cerda which comes through
not from Barcelonans.
I don't know the Barcelona
literature extensively,
but a man has recently
written a book
pointing out that Cerda belonged
to a small group of people,
intellectuals in Barcelona who
were attracted to socialism.
Amongst their members was
a man called [INAUDIBLE],,
who was one of the designers
of the modern submarine.
Strange people.
Poets.
Apparently, they were
very influenced by French
intellectual utopianist called
Etienne Cabet, C-A-B-E-T,
who wrote a book called
A Voyage to Icaria.
Cabet proposed in his ideal
city a center with the capital,
and then an equal
distribution of space
every 360 degrees
around the center.
Cabet worked in the
British Museum reading room
just like Marx did.
I don't think they
knew each other.
They were years apart.
Cabet insisted that
the United States
was the place to build a
utopia, as many Europeans did.
Fourier, for instance.
There's a paradox about Fourier
and the Fourierist community
in the United States, but that's
for another class when you talk
about utopianism next week.
Cabet bought land in New Orleans
and took 79 Cabetians with him
to New Orleans.
They hated New Orleans.
The climate was awful.
They didn't know anything
about the land they bought.
They were sold a piece of
land which was really bad.
They moved north to Nauvoo,
N-A-U-V-O-O, Illinois,
which is one of the sequence
of places that the Mormons
capitalized on on the trek from
the East Coast to Salt Lake
City.
They took over Nauvoo,
Illinois, which didn't succeed.
[INAUDIBLE],, for instance,
wanted to join them.
He wrote to Etienne Cabet, but
Cabet had died in the meantime,
and the whole enterprise
suffered terribly.
How much of this Cerda knew
or how much of this Cerda
was interested in is
difficult to know.
He remains an enigmatic
figure but a man
who achieved enormous amounts.
His plan was built, built
to a certain degree.
The grid system was maintained,
but the amount and disposition
of this site changed.
It's in the diagram on one
of the pages I gave you.
We'll see Cerda's wish to have
a fluctuating system, where
the site was either occupied
by two buildings, three
buildings, or four completely
enclosed by four buildings.
For Cerda, the
height of the facade
was to be limited
to three floors.
There were no elevators
in existence yet.
Anyway.
The height of the blocks
were 16 meters maximum.
That's a ground floor
and three floors,
and the maximum
coverage was 50%.
Cerda had very little to do with
the application of the plan.
Here there was no accompanying
policy to make sure
who lived in the space.
The number of
devices which we've
invented since Cerda's time to
make sure that we have a mixed
population in space sometimes
as simply as putting
a percentage, 15% on new
development in Cambridge,
Massachusetts to be allocated
to affordable housing
as a part of any
building of new housing.
There was nothing like that.
Cerda envisioned an
equal spatial plan,
and isotropic plan
spatially, but he
didn't understand how to get
an isotropic distribution
of population.
He envisioned baker's living
next to bankers, communities
within this grid, each
with their own school,
and so on, and so on, and so
on, but he played little role
that I know in the
execution of the plan.
There's a great--
oh, I've got to rush.
There's a great paradox here.
Over time, ensanche
has become developed
at a much greater density.
Coverage was increased from
50% to 70%, even more than 70%.
Height was increased
to 24 meters.
The volume of Cerda's
plan was supposed
to be 67,000 meters squared.
The 1958 volume of what
has being built on his plan
is over three times as
much, 290,000 square meters.
The paradox is that if you go
down the [INAUDIBLE],, which
is the great road built through
the ensanche, this great avenue
which I'll show you
an image of, you
can feel the pedestrian volume.
He allowed five meters
of pedestrian width
throughout the scheme.
There's an intensity of urban
intensity in this area, which
is part of its charm.
Cerda's plan was so
pro forma in a sense
that it allowed so
many things to happen
after his time, such as the
increase of density and still,
except for automobile traffic,
able to cope with the world.
The fact that he made
sideways sidewalks that
were all that wide
was an indication
of some thinking about
the advent of density.
He didn't include techniques
which could frustrate
subsequent development.
What happened is
that, as you'll see--
let's look at the pictures now.
The Danube, and Vienna
below on the southern border
of the Danube next.
The walls as walkways and
pedestrian perambulation zones
prior to their being removed.
The glacis on the right.
Next.
The clear space
after the walls have
been taken down, and the
filling in of this space
with a single spine.
Next.
The parliament, town
hall, university, theater,
accommodation.
That's Hitler's drawing of
the parliament, by the way.
Not bad.
He should've got into
architecture school.
Next.
The medieval town hall,
which still exists.
Next.
A [INAUDIBLE],, an
apartment building.
Large blocks, large volume, and
the phenomenon [? again in ?]
[? the ?] facade of decorating
the facade with sculpture.
This is not a flat facade.
Next.
The entrance to the
apartment building
has this zone of almost
regal or royal pertinence.
Again, these decorative
system which is open and free,
giving spatial quality to
the extrinsic experience.
Next.
And Camillo Sitte, a
critique of the what
he calls the turbine
plaza, a plaza in which you
enter and move--
a plaza which is
correctly organized,
where you enter and leave
only in special places.
In the center of
the plaza is a space
for emotional contemplation.
His proposal in the shaded
zones for recreating a proper
appearance in front of the
[? votive ?] [? church, ?]
breaking down the openness,
which is credited to actors
called [INAUDIBLE].
He was afraid of open space,
demarcating space in relation
to particular buildings.
Next.
Otto Wagner's impression for
the expansion of the city
is a series of zones
that articulated
by a kind of expansionist line.
Here is his design
for one of the--
sorry-- or one of the proposed
extension expansion areas.
Next.
His preoccupation with
designing industrial buildings.
This is sluice building
on the Danube canal.
You can see these are--
can you see the wavelike
decoration up on the right?
This is a man who's carrying
a kind of hybrid system
in his head, on the one hand,
wanting to make something as
decidedly modern as possible.
On the other, decorating it
with a frieze facade decoration.
His subway stop, the Karlsplatz.
Next.
His buildings in the railways
[INAUDIBLE] new railway system.
At the same time, this is
a competition entry of his.
I can't remember what
the building was.
I think the Academy
of Fine Arts,
and this is the Postal
Savings Bank building,
where the decorative
system is on the facade
in between the regular
machine-like windows.
Next.
I didn't have time to go
into this in greater detail,
but this is Joseph Hoffman's
work in the industrial design
sector in the great
advances in modern design,
using new materials.
This is a list of the
theater performances
for the weekend in Vienna.
Next.
Mahler's great Symphony
Number Six, and, to my mind,
greatest book of
Freud's interpretation
of dreams in 1911.
Next.
Karl Marx-Hof and some
of the other hof blocks.
Karl Marx-Hof on the left.
I think it's 1 and
1/2 kilometers long.
Next.
The abiding preoccupation
with sculpture and a flag.
These arches are not entrances.
They're zones of penetration.
These are the entrance zones.
Again, they decorate.
Apartments are very small.
Once when I was
visiting this building,
the taxi driver had lived
in this Karl Marx-Hof,
and he said he left
because he couldn't
swing a cat in his apartment.
Those were his words.
[LAUGHTER]
An enormously powerful
manifestation.
Michael Graves must have
looked at this architecture
to gain some inspiration
for his buildings.
Next.
Barcelona.
Look at the size of the ensanche
compared to the old city,
and you can imagine what Cerda
would have done to Paris,
the [INAUDIBLE] of Paris.
It's worth spending
10 minutes to talk
about that as an
alternative model for what
the post-modern Paris
competition's entries did.
Next.
Cerda's vision, a
three-floor set of blocks
differentiating
between two blocks
which only had one arm
on them, others which
had two buildings, some which
had three buildings, some where
the square was enclosed.
What was actually built is
represented on the right--
enclosed space in the
center, not public space,
but ambiguous space, sometimes
space which was taken over
by residents, sometimes space
which was made into parking
lots, sometimes space
which is just dilapidated,
but no resolution of the
internal space [? of a ?]
consolidated four-sided block.
Next.
You can see some of
the interior of the--
there's a difference
between making Karl Marx-Hof
interior space as a space for
the community with clinics,
shops, medical facilities,
schools, and so on as
a concept.
This is a concept which enclosed
a block in order to galvanize
the quality of the street,
to increase density,
but left the whole
completely unavailable.
Next.
Cerda's plan calls
for the blocks
to be truncated on the corners.
Here you can see an intersection
of the four corners,
leaving a messy transportation
intersection problem there.
One of the arguments made
by the Barcelonans today
is that this creates
another facade,
and each of these small
square intersections
have unique facades
facing onto them.
Next.
[INAUDIBLE],, the medieval public
walk, and the [INAUDIBLE],,
this great avenue which
links to the town of Gracia
in the hills.
Next.
The [INAUDIBLE]
[? guardian. ?] Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] on the left, the
[INAUDIBLE] on the right.
Next.
A great unfinished
cathedral, an attempt
to modernize the ensanche.
Next.
The Barcelona Games
is the only games
that position the
center of the city
as central to the four sides--
the [INAUDIBLE] side on the
top left, the [INAUDIBLE] side
for the athletes' housing.
Of all the Olympic sites, from
Munich, to Tokyo, to Sydney,
to Melbourne, London, and
so on, none of [INAUDIBLE]
incorporated the proposition
within the central city system.
Next.
Two post-Cerda propositions.
Could you just focus
this one please?
Thank you.
This is Corbusier's
and a group called
[INAUDIBLE],, a modern version
of the extension of the Cerda
system.
The streets are
gone, or they ignored
the [INAUDIBLE] system of
Corbusier's engaged in housing.
There's a huge
amount of open space
which is not allocated
to anybody in particular.
One prefers the scheme
on the left infinitely.
A crazy man, Lon Krier,
saying that the problem with
Cerda's plan is the 113
meter size is too large.
Krier has a dislike of
anything continuous,
so he suggests that
the clock be broken up
into four modules
of 25 meters each,
where he believed
the market is for all
of the shopping on
these little corners,
and the confusion caused
by creating as many corners
as you like.
Lon Krier should visit Tel Aviv
and see what happens when you
subdivide blocks into
two smaller distance.
It's a silly diagram, but
two examples of post-Cerda
thinking.
I think that's a lot.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Oh, sorry.
The idea of expanding from--
by leaving the center allowed
an expanding outwards.
This is Antonelli's
plan for Torino.
That is Custer's
plan for Madrid.
Next.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
plan for [INAUDIBLE],,
and this is
[? Kritanthis's ?] plan--
[? Krianthis-Schubert's ?]
plan for Athens.
All suggest in the
dark gray that you
maintain the core of
the city, take away
the walls if necessary, and
produce a free zone outside.
Next.
Here in the small town
of Altamura in Apulia,
you see the system
operating in a small town.
Radiating outwards are
gates to the old city.
I haven't got time to
go into the detail.
Here you see a grid
system employed almost
throughout the surroundings
of the existing walled city.
If the walls are
taken away or replaced
by a boulevard
surrounding the city,
nothing like the boulevard
of the Ringstrasse.
OK.
Sorry it's so rushed, but the
world is full of information.